speaking of shaq look at this i have a
picture of you guys
uh being inducted into this
a hall of fame and i have questions
about shaq
because i i talk to him from time to
time he thinks in an
interesting way for example recently
he said that he thought that the earth
and the moon were closer to one another
than new york and chicago is that right
yes he said uh we were honoring john
glenn who passed away and he says the
great astronaut
yeah yeah and he said is it closer to
the moon
or l.a and ernest is what you mean he
says when you walk outside you can see
the moon but you can't see la
and we're like we're like what are you
seeing he's like
yeah hey conan and he's 100 percent
serious he's just
i'm being serious you walk outside you
can see the moon
you can't see and you see what i have to
work with man
yeah yeah it's interesting he says these
things and i've talked to him
and every time he says them i think wait
a minute that's it that's a provocative
question he says it in a way that
actually gets me thinking
now i know the moon is much farther away
but then he asks me then how come we can
see them and
it's just fascinating no one thinks like
that no no
it's not fascinating he's just a dumbass
sometimes
now you must be a big fan of uh shaq's
life uh
shaq's show shack life you must really
love that show
i lived in life there's nothing on that
show that i haven't seen
except hanging out with his 22 kids i
mean that's the only thing that's
different
hey he does he he's the same way every
week
the only difference about the show is
he's got a commercial to shoot every
week
the only thing different i don't go home
and hang out with uh the bad kids he got
but that's the only difference
and you maintains you maintain you don't
think shaq
uses any of those products that he's out
there you don't think he
he you don't think he uh he buys his
insurance through the general
you don't think he uses icy hot i
guarantee you he has not
used any product that he endorses
i guarantee you he has not used any
product
first of all i will give him credit he
is a great
great businessman yes but i guarantee
you he's
never used any products he's endorsed
now what do you think about his style uh
and i bring this up for a reason
you've been criticized recently
for sometimes what you wear on the show
for example russell westbrook said
you're the worst dresser on the show
inside the nba and people point to this
outfit this glitter outfit that you are
wearing what's going on with this outfit
please
best chess outfit conan i know but why
are you wearing it
because i want to see everybody see how
ridic first of all how big it was and
how ridiculous he looked in it
i would never wear that thing but shaq
wore that one night
and i took it off later and wore it
another night to look like the idiot he
looked like on the show that night
so you're saying that you're taking heat
because sometimes people just see the
photograph
and think you're wearing this and they
don't know and they say
charles barkley can't dress for [ __ ] you
were just wearing
shaq's outfit to prove how horrible it
is
conan i've never been drunk enough to
have my taylor make that outfit right
there
ever and he and he thinks he looks good
in it
yeah and he that that was an awful
glittery thing
but you couldn't tell him that he
thought he was styling and profiling
yeah he did he thought he would but that
was ugly yeah no he was dressed like an
ice skater like a figure skater
it's absurd
you